hat er mir auch schon gesagt er ist dass
die ganze mit den schildern so freunde
weiter geht's mit fiete wies wird gerade
nacht immer noch ohne face cam hier am
start ganz einfach weil die alle ist
weil ich ja vorhin jetzt warte für
folgen habe ich jetzt mit festem wieder
aufgenommen es sind genau sechs folgen
also halbstundentakt immer mit vollem
akku aber danach nicht einfach ab und wo
wir stehen geblieben genau ich habe mir
den rotary major gemacht er ist wieder
ordentlich auf speed er geht jetzt
allerdings gleich wieder runter weil er
halt grad nicht in verwendung ist der
ist jetzt aufspielt 38 bleibt er stehen
ich hab ne menge kohle das abkommen ich
habe auch zwei cup und plate und den
mixed metal links habe ich schon das
heißt den pakt jetzt eben den kompressor
fein und dann kriegt dann links raus
diese komischen advant erneut und habe
euch noch maschinen blog wie mache ich
mir nochmal maschinen blog ist das
einfach wie faymann rief ein mann habe
ich ja hier noch drin liegen
ich mache jeden fall schon mal ein paar
mehr habe ich gar nicht manchmal schon
mal soviel maschinenparks wie ich machen
kann
3 die braucht man auf jeden fall immer
wieder immer wieder
somit schien block in der mitte carbon
platten machen der komplex war einst
habe ich schon
danach kann ich mir mit diesem advent
einen blog mache ich mir dann ich zeig
euch mal ganz kurz
den hier den induction furness dafür
broich noch kopper electric furness als
ich den elektriker den bauherren ab das
ist der hier gerade da ist auch das
dings schmiedet da sie ganz unbeholfen
drin oben unten rechts links so dass ein
staat heißt es tut mir leid aber ich
muss sich jetzt leider abbauen
dankeschön
so bräuchte es noch nicht auch jetzt
allerdings dass hier block kommt
dahinter kommt der lektorin und da kommt
jetzt das ganze branche zeug zum don ich
schon einmal ganz kurz um
internet-aktien das geht jetzt auf raps
drauf kann sein dass ein pc gleich
wieder abstürzt ich hoffe nicht ich
werde jetzt aktion für das minecraft
mache immer zwischendurch katz einfach
so alle halbe stunde oder so
dax tec entwickeln jedoch ist doch
normales kopper okay gut
ich dachte dass seine teams weil in
dieser abbildung und witz in dieser
abbildung ist ja einmal körper gesagt
hat das papier steht einfach ich kann
das auch hier mitmachen da für diesen
dings was sie gerade hatte aber nein
funktioniert nicht und da ist er und der
ist auf jeden fall schon mal viel besser
an als liebes musste macht es dadurch
quasi das gleiche repertoire us aircraft
bei sich zu hause auch hat das puzzle
timo schön war es erneut blablabla ärzte
dann glaube ich oder das ist kein
ernster
was keine quiksilver richtig machen ich
brauche jetzt mal neue sachen die ich
mir machen kann quiksilver toll was gar
nicht mitmachen
das kann man die leaks selber machen so
etwas was brauchen sonst also ich kann
bei den anderen ist ein bisschen gucken
und gleich noch die gleichen sachen die
ich oder kompressor was man sonst noch
so durch industrial kraft 22 18
das ist das auch nicht weiter
das trio kraft was brauchen da alter
okay das sind viele sachen
da habe ich alles schon kenning
maschinen
das bringt den trader martha lectures so
ein potpourri auch noch ich schaue noch
mal ganz kurz vor der mine betreten
verboten
ich meine was soll ich denn jetzt noch
für maschinen hier alter da hinten hin
schwer ein schild an der völlig gleiche
höhe ich lach mich tot
dann können uns jetzt eigentlich schon
mal aussetzen können uns jetzt schon mal
anders heraus setzt das heißt diese farm
wird erstmal verkleinert wird gar nicht
mehr bestehen
so leute werden es jetzt jedenfalls ein
paar folge ich denke noch 45 folgen
jetzt erstmal nur mit fiete wies
beschäftigt es war nicht wie dazu
gekommen aber wir haben auf jeden fall
upgegradet schön freut mich und meine
jungs heute noch machen dass die mir da
die sachen aus kam dann wirklich sagen
wir uns noch am zaubern
weil dann kann ich hier ja dies mache
kann ich mir so ein vor baustart machen
wir denn die mikrowelt er
jakob in ihrem untergrund darf man alles
abbauen und komme dann kann ich euch das
gleich an diesem beispiel von dem koffer
ärzten zeigen wie ich das bei mir mit
dem rotary mitstreitern so was alles
vorgestellt hatte übrigens noch einige
ich sollte den stein von den vulkanen
mitnehmen um mir daraus das haus bauen
weil es angeblich richtig geil aussehen
sollte und so hell die zu hause schon
welche gewesen wären
gut ich gehe mal wieder raus zurück zum
grundstück ich wollte das einfach nur
mit erde jetzt zu bauen was hat dir hier
eigentlich alles der mce export ach so
ich wollte einen standort zu bauen höhe
hatte jedoch schon gesagt er ist dass
die ganze mit den schildern
wenn ich habe nicht gesehen dass
eingezäunt ist vielleicht ist es doch
einfach einer der irgendwie zugang zum
server hat
dort verbringt das als ersten pulver
auch schon
extractor hat general james ray austin
regelverstoß ich wollte nur gucken und
fett
walter hält glaube ich auch ahnung davon
und ich weiß gar nicht was das ist
ein schön gestaltetes grundstück somit
naturell blabla deswegen also ich glaube
ich werde mich jetzt wirklich erstmals
haus letztlich habe der 20 so viel bock
drauf nicht an dass unser vertrauen über
bringt nix ja dann setze ich mich
erstmals konnten so also jetzt mal ganz
kurz gezeigt ich mag das jetzt einfach
gehen den rotary maze runner rhein dann
steigert sich kurz die energie wie hoch
die musste erst mal aufgeladen werden
komisch ich glaube ich kaum ein
komplettes fällt erst mal im wechsel der
ernte das ab und an als opa weil es gibt
zurzeit holz auf den plätzen folgen das
kann ich später machen
und 18 jähriges kind aber ich weiß auch
gar nicht ich kann nicht zu bauen das
ist denn das ist meine sache dass es
krisen kraftwerk bauen hat es einfach so
kann ich jetzt kollektion von mir
vermindern
aber ich weiß halt ist nicht was ich mir
da jetzt hin zu non sich einfach wasser
drückt mir das selber bin ich für meine
maschinen klaus wahrscheinlich so ein
riesiges gehwege machen
ehrlich gesagt habe ich keinen bock ist
seit kurzem spricht dass ich irgendwas
weg firma day of the game
da kommen sehen ich meine es trocken
doch nachher seite aus
wenn in der aufnahme aber wollt in 20
jungen auf können heute abend reiche
land
wir schreiben anfachen
ich hasse dieses weib gemacht habe
nowitzki wollte schauen ob wir alles und
in der aufnahme bei schreiben georg oder
g rennen
das war der mit diesen schildern das
fahrzeug geht immer drauf und schreibt
diese scheiß schilder dass das ist sehr
all das ist das projekt prozentig ist
das sonnig es ist einfach so also jetzt
hab ich hier zum beispiel den den koffer
das den park jetzt hier in den
förderverein alter das ich mich gerade
frage ich schaue mal ganz kurz bei k 4 1
ja kaum ihr wollt doch das alles immer
sehen wir nicht nur gladbeck rumfliegen
blabla ich schaue mal ganz kurz bei
cathy einfach rein
warum hat käfer dauernd energie
ich meine dass es immer 100% warte da
7500 das ist bei mir nur dem gesamten
rhein lege arbeiten oder hat er hier so
eine bestimmte bett box jetzt an die
klasse fuß nichts passiert ich dachte
ich schaue mir dass er nur an
freundinnen
ich hab mir nach ich bekomm moment nicht
nur eine moment warte ich checke das mal
ganz kurz er jetzt habt ihr kurzer zeit
mir das in die kommentare zu schreiben
wie ich auch unendlich strom kriege
lassen das eigentlich auch das ist ein f
e ach so das ändern natürlich wieder die
lage fest gibt's gleich auch noch oder
was hat er da ist es eine ganz normale
bett boxee data hat das ist keine
normale notebooks ganz kurz beim ihren
vergleiche mit meiner
neben einer sieht anders aus
gut schaut mir erstmal ganz gut bei ihm
an und zwar der der wasserkraft das
heißt er hat hier einfach so einen
ziemlich hohen wasserturm wo diese
ganzen dreck die sachen drin sind und
die münden dann unten in dem ft
ich dachte man da hätte da auch schon
links daran einfach so keinen der die
energie normal so gespeichert sag ich
mal ich kann mich nicht gut ausdrücken
scheiß ich habe mein fenster verzogen
fakt ist die größe anders freu mich
machen zwei minuten kurz eckardt dann
möchten wir besser mf e-energy christel
ok goldbarren und rapper brauche ich
dann machen wir jeden fall schon mal
diese kerle
allerdings würde ich sagen dass manche
nächsten folge war ich hab kein bock
dass es nachher wieder unnötig
verschieben skalieren muss in premiere
deswegen fliege ich kurz zu meinem
grundstück sagt üblichen wort von wegen
hacker am hoch also ich würd mich freuen
wenn ihr wenn es euch gefallen daumen
hoch geben weil das zeigt mir dass ich
so was gefällt wenn ich nicht so
informiere und sowas machen und blau und
plopp und ja und ja ich muss ganz kurz
gucken ich habe gar nicht mehr ich habe
kein gold besitzt einfach nur dick ist
das volk ein ding rein
ich habe kein gold herstellen
schauen wir uns kurz gold ja genau mache
ich auch so aus dem gold schwert oder
kann ich auch nicht ich brauche gold
induction smelter gold jetzt sowas
einfach ja jetzt kriegt irgendwo anders
hin
nee ich brauch gold cable
fahrt mal ein gold 4 weber 3 gold ja
okay dann wird sehr theoretisch auch so
gehen um euch jetzt erst mal aber ich
hab kein rabatt
ich habe einfach keinen aber ist das ist
das einzige ich habe alles im überfluss
aber ich habe keinen aber und ich kann
das gar nicht sortieren weil er alles
von gold ist back oder warum ist das
hier am rhein
ach freunde ich brauche aber ich muss
einfach demnächst mal wieder mit dem
anders aufnehmen der mir dann eventuell
acht ich habe das ding ist ein bisschen
ranocchia
ach so das wollte ich auch machen wäre
ja so das wollte ich auch machen und
diese bäume einfach runter schrauben zu
hoch schrauben
damit ich las die größe einfach mal so
dann habe ich als nachher diesmal zu
verstellen ich mache das kloster höhe
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal freunde